so welcome to building an open-source
artificial pancreas hopefully you're in
the right room by the way I'm honored to
be here because I've been to strange
loop I think four or five times now but
this is my first time speaking so I'm
really excited to be here yeah and here
it is here's the open source artificial
pancreas thank you all for coming have a
great day and talk to you later yeah
okay okay um if you're like most of my
friends you've kind of heard that and
thought like what the heck what does
that even mean um I expected it to be in
you not actually in a little cute pink
pouch or something um so you probably
have a bunch of questions and I hope to
answer all of those in this session so
brief introduction my name is Sarah with
E I'm a software engineer based out of
Pittsburgh I do all sorts of things
different languages I kind of like the
variety to my life I've been in my past
a robot in hardware tinkerer so I was on
a robotics competition team in college
I've helped kids in robotics
competitions or win world championships
stuff like that um I've also done a
variety of conference speaking teach
workshops and different things like that
one thing I haven't really talked about
that much in my life is that I'm a type
1 diabetic and that's kind of one of the
basis of this talk but um I think
there's a lot of stigmas in our society
so I kept quiet for a long time but this
technology has been really so cool that
I wanted to start sharing it but before
I can really talk about an artificial
pancreas and what it does and the
problems it solves I think we need to
talk a little bit about the science
first so to go a bit into carbohydrates
everybody heard of carbohydrates I hope
yeah so when you eat carbohydrates and
that includes different forms of sugar
um your body breaks it down into glucose
and fructose and for this talk we don't
care about fructose we'll just kind of
toss it in the imaginary trashcan that
glucose then goes into our bloodstream
and from there your pancreas will see
that rise in glucose and say hey I need
to make this insulin which is a hormone
and it sort of this effect so it sees it
goes up it starts to make more insulin
once your cells see this insulin in
there that tells them oh hey take this
glucose and start using it as energy so
the central process is basically all of
the cells in your body need glucose to
work but it can't use that glucose
without this insulin in your bloodstream
as well and diabetes is just when this
process doesn't work that's it I think
people tend to equate it with fat people
that like cookies and well I do like
cookies that it's not necessarily what
that process means and you've probably
heard of the two types so type one is
it's an autoimmune disease so your body
ends up attacking its own insulin making
cells so you don't make insulin anymore
so this whole process doesn't work you
can't use those cells or use that
glucose type to is where you still make
the insulin but your body just doesn't
want to use it anymore
so for whatever reason you know you can
keep making it it just kind of sits
there and your body's not responding to
it there's some other rarer types as
well you may have heard of gestational
diabetes which is where when you become
pregnant
your body becomes resistant to that
insulin sometimes it's temporary so a
month or two after you're done with the
pregnancy you can kind of go back where
you were
sometimes it's permanent I'm a friend of
mine back where I used to live now has
just type 1 diabetes because her body
didn't recover from it and then there's
a few other types here I won't really go
into those technically I don't have the
autoimmune disease I have one of these
other types my doctor and I aren't quite
sure we never ended up running some
expensive tests to find out so I'm
actually one of these rarer types but we
just treat it like type one just like
normal so what we do to measure the
glucose in our bloodstream since it's
kind of an important issue I'm in the
u.s. we use milligrams per deciliter and
in other countries they use millimoles
per liter so I'm gonna stick with the
u.s. system just for kind of a solid
basis so typical glucose ranges in your
bloodstream for normal people as I like
to call you the civilians they range
from about 70 to 100
grams per deciliter and after you eat
meals obviously some of your
carbohydrates to process your Bloods
gonna temporarily go up but then it's
going to come back down as your body
processes that since diabetics have to
manage this ourselves doctors usually
try to say you know keep it in the 80 to
150 range just to be a little safe you
know and after you eat obviously it's
going to go up so it's like 80 to 180 so
these numbers are important because bad
things happen if they go to higher go to
low so if your glucose glucose goes to
high you have what's called
hyperglycemia and that's basically where
you start to have bad circulation
problems so little glucose molecules get
clogged in your capillaries the really
really tiny blood vessels and so you
start to have circulation problems that
kind of compound over time so it clogs
your capillaries things like your eyes
have lots of capillaries in them so
people's eyesight tends to go bad
kidneys have a lot of these so your
kidneys start to function weird or
possibly just not function at all
fingers and toes have a lot of them so
that's why there's a lot of foot
problems with people and other diabetics
and things like this so basically slowly
your organs start to fail so we
definitely don't want this sugar to go
too high if it goes too low we have
hypoglycemia and so we have kind of this
weird effect of people start shaking
sweating they get really weak I usually
have to set for about 20 minutes because
it's just like I can't hardly stand up
straight I feel like I'm gonna fall over
so basically your body just starts
freaking out like oh my gosh I don't
have enough glucose to keep going so you
start kind of going crazy all over if
you've ever waited a really long time
before you eat or in between meals
something like eight ten twelve hours
you can start to have some of these
effects as well but diabetics can't
really recover from this so um best-case
scenario you have to just eat a bunch of
sugar and you can recover in about 20
minutes
worst case scenario you can land in the
hospital some have diabetic comas if
this happens in your sleep
some people have died from this so this
is not a thing to just shrug off lightly
it's really important so this is why we
have
to kind of keep these glucose levels in
order normal people often aren't told
the warning signs until it's too late I
landed in the ER for something
completely unrelated and they said we
have to do surgery on you we need to do
a typical run in the mill blood test I'm
like okay and they came back in like
your blood Sugar's over 400 like I don't
know what that means they're like you're
diabetic and they thought originally I
was typed too eventually we found that I
was type 1 and eventually found out like
oh hey you're this weird type over there
but the other thing is once people are
diagnosed often they're told either too
little information are just way too much
when I laughed a diabetic educator had
come to my room multiple times and left
me pamphlets and booklets and I probably
left with literally 30 booklets it's it
was just drastic overkill and I learned
more from Wikipedia later it just wasn't
really worth it so diabetes is kind of
complicated this is my prescription at
the moment Humalog is one of the brands
of insulin and basically your usual
prescriptions are take two pills twice a
day or take one pill at every meal or
something like that I literally just
have a blanket statement that's like
take some as you need it don't take more
than 120 that's super vague right it's
entirely up to me to figure out how much
of this medicine I have to take and so
it gets a little complicated um so what
is a unit of insulin a unit of insulin
is basically 1/100 of a milliliter
that's not super important so it's just
we refer to units because it's just kind
of easier but everybody has a carb ratio
and that's for every amount of carbs
that you eat you have to have so much
insulin the counteracted um and all of
you have a corporation as well you
probably don't know it but that's fine
your body kind of takes care of that
but these range typically from like
three grams to one unit to 50 grams per
unit so this range is really huge
and in the beginning you just kind of
have to take a wild guess it's usually
based on weight and body size and
different things like that but you kind
of have to just fine-tune it over time
so it's a whole lot of experimentation
in the beginning to make this even more
complicated these carb ratios vary
they vary from person to person so if
you look to your left and look to your
right you all have different card ratios
um it can change from different times of
the day - I need more insulin in the
morning than I do in the evening I have
no clue why I just do it can change
under different conditions so like I
just said when I'm sleeping I need a
less than I do in the morning if I'm
stressed if I'm sick all these different
things can change this ratio and this
will change over my lifespan my rate is
different now than what it was when I
was first diagnosed so to make this even
more complicated because it's not
complicated yet um when you eat carbs it
takes about 10 to 20 minutes before your
body starts to absorb that and it goes
into your bloodstream
and the insulin we have to take doesn't
take effect immediately it's kind of
designed to slowly pick up the pace so
once you take it there's about this
45-minute waiting period where it kind
of like slowly ramps up and then it just
like hit you hard core about this 45 to
60 minute range but really takes
effectively five hours for your body to
absorb the whole thing and this little
chart here is kind of it's a little
weird to look at but the blue line is
the absorption rate so it starts off
slow it picks up and then it kind of
tapers over time and the purple area
shows that reduction rate so if you have
a bunch of glucose it slowly kind of
picks up and then Falls a lot quicker
and then tapers off over that five hours
so to counteract the glucose levels you
have to take different doses of this
medicine we have - we typically refer to
some ones called a bolus and that's I
ate some food I take the medicine for it
so I just had some pasta out there that
has a bunch of carbs I have to take the
insulin for that I'm a basil is an
all-day rate so my group my
liver is very kind and it makes glucose
for me all day long but I still need the
insulin for it so I literally just have
to have a stream of this medicine 24/7
are you all overwhelmed yet I see one
head shaking like no okay let's make it
more complicated if you're stressed your
body will respond by raising your
glucose a bit if you're sick your
glucose will also rise a bit if you're
exercising or doing other physical
activity really hard that's gonna make
your glucose go down if you have a
little bit to drink that'll go up a lot
of alcohol has carbs in it if you drink
too much your glucose is going to go
down because your blood composition
changes a bit so it has all these like
side effects and remember how I said
hypoglycemia is like really terrible or
you're weak and you're shaking and I get
like foggy headed you don't really want
to be drunk and have all that going on
it's a really terrible combination and
then finally if it's that special time
of the month right ladies it could go up
it could possibly go down and we're
possibly up or possibly down there but
anyway so this kind of adds to the
complication of it's not just a simple
you know give a dose things magically
work there's always variables that are
constantly changing is this all good so
far okay you're all like yeah I could
totally do this okay let's make it some
work let's make it more complicated if
you're high you have to bring it back
down right you can't use a carb ratio to
bring it back down you need another
ratio and that's called an insulin
sensitivity factor and that's basically
how much your body will use extra
insulin to reduce its own values so
basically however high you are of Mg
deals above where you need to be you
need to take so much insulin to reduce
it this also varies per person varies
over time etc etc so this is always a
fun level and my rate now is not the
rate that I had in the beginning either
cool so we talked about exercise briefly
so this consumes glucose because you're
using a lot of energy your cells need
that extra fuel source and your blood
sugar will end up dropping fast
if you don't account for this so when I
exercise I have to take anywhere from
half of my normal rate of insulin to
sometimes no insulin and the fact this
is one of my bike rides I did a few
weeks ago where when I woke up it's kind
of about ninety eighty or so I had two
breakfast sandwiches and I had my bike
on my car and I drove in the McDonald's
it felt so weird to have a bike in
McDonald's um binge it out on breakfast
food so it shot up and then I biked it
all off and actually went all the way
back down
I burned off all of those carbs and I
took no medicine for it which is
something I have to factor into if I
know I'm gonna work a bunch so kind of
combine all together all these things
are just sort of scary and it scares a
lot of people especially when they've
been first diagnosed they don't know how
to manage all this because doctors are
usually just like I think you need I
don't know for every 10 grams of carbs
you eat take it unit of insulin here's
your prescription have a good day
and so it's a lot harder to manage and I
think we don't give people credit for
this and I'm really good at math and
science so all this makes sense to be
and I have trouble so you can imagine
people that just aren't really good at
math people that just don't get the
concepts of all this and they struggle
with this thing so hopefully we're at a
technology conference in you're all are
thinking like wait a minute Sarah like
certainly technology can solve this
problem and sure we have a couple main
things of Technology come on sides there
we go um so there's two main technology
pieces that can help with this and the
first one is called a continuous glucose
monitor and the second one is an insulin
pump and you've probably seen these on
people before a continuous glucose
monitor um it's a little simple thing I
want on my arm right here
you're welcome to come up and take a
look at it later so it's kind of stuck
to my arm there's a little sticker
around the outside and it has this
really fine needle it's it's like hair
it's really flexible and it's just kind
of like a little bit under my skin every
five to 15 minutes it measures my
glucose level and then reports that over
Bluetooth to my phone so I actually have
an app on my phone that says right now
I'm about 102 anybody remembers that's
good or bad pretty good yeah I'm 102
right now so every five minutes I get a
little data point on my phone that tells
me what things are going and I even have
a little thing on my homescreen I just
turn on my phone I can just see what my
number is an insulin pump is another
thing that a lot of type one diabetics
have just because it delivers I'm just
you know that stream of insulin you can
see mind sort of attached to me I can't
really pull it off so it's actually it's
trying to dos right now that's cool um
so all day long it has my basal rate -
programmed into it so it's giving me a
little bit constantly throughout the day
I can also pull it out and punch a
number into it I want well five units of
insulin and it'll just give it to me
so um looks like a little pager I pretty
much have to have it connected to me I
take it off for showers that's about it
really
um the main problem is these two things
don't talk to each other there are two
independent things and I'm the one that
has to look at my blood sugar and then
determine what I'm going to do about it
and I just have to do this all day long
so that's kind of annoying but also
we're still at a technology conference
and hopefully you're all thinking like
wait I miss here certainly there's
technology to fix this and you're right
that's finally it took 17 minutes to get
there but that's where the artificial
pancreas comes in as I like to say
taking my body into the 21st century
there's three main systems that are out
there and the first one is called open
APS and that's the one I run
open artificial pancreas system so it's
a linux-based IOT device so this is
actually a little chip on there it runs
Linux it has all the memory and
everything kind of on the same chip it's
also attached to a 900 megahertz trance
transceiver borden so your phone doesn't
communicate over that frequency which is
why you sorta need the extra device and
it's kind of weird that it needs a
really old Medtronic pump in Medtronic's
just one of the brains that makes
insulin pumps and you need an old one
because people found the security flaw
and the radiofrequency it uses normally
security flaws are a bad thing but in
this case it's a good thing because that
security flaw enables this type of
system and it's really kind of cool and
they found it and they fixed it in newer
ones which is why you need an old pump
i'm lipcott is the other really big
major one and it also needs bluetooth
too 915 megahertz board but this board
kind of just doesn't do any of the
calculations on it it's just kind of a
simple communication so it gets the
Bluetooth thing and since the commands
to a pump it does everything on an iOS
application so you have to have an Apple
device to do this
the unfortunate thing is it's not on the
Apple Store so you actually have to
download the code you have to compile it
you have to self sign it and then upload
it to your phone so you can possibly see
that people who aren't developers
probably have not the foggiest idea what
they're doing that's kind of one of the
downsides of this particular system we
also have Android APs
so it's the artificial pancreas system
but it's built onto an Android app so it
kind of works similar to open APs they
tweaked some of the algorithms a bit for
their software and I'll go into that a
little bit later but this one works with
mostly European pumps and while you
could probably ship a pump over from
overseas all the supplies that you need
are still over in Europe so you'd be
constantly having the ship stuff and
insurance companies don't really like
that because you have American stuff why
not just use the American things so I
can't really jump on board with this one
and then I said there were three there's
this fourth one here so this is a
Medtronic 670 it is a commercial product
it's closed source its proprietary
Medtronic doesn't want you to know
anything about how this thing works
but they try to make it as a one size
fits all system which in a way I can
kind of see that but as you've hopefully
seen for the first half of this talk
there's a lot of things going on there's
a lot of variables you really kind of
need a system designed for you and as
such they have a lot of conservative
algorithms so they usually have just
we're keeping you as close to 150 as we
can or if you're exercising we're
assuming you always want to you know be
at this level things like that so we're
kind of gonna ignore that for the rest
of our talk so what the process happens
is your little CGM your continuous
glucose monitor get your blood sugar
about you so that's the top left corner
it passes those over to your phone and
in this case I run an open-source app
called extra I mean it collects those
blood sugar values from my glucose
monitor and then it sends those to a
Heroku app called Knight Scout and
knights Cal it's also open source so you
deploy this to Heroku and it just kind
of runs in the background they have an
azure version but they're kind of
phasing that out so from there your
artificial pancreas system can download
some of these values over different
periods of time spot the trends that are
going on with you so it looks at how
much food you ate it looks at your
recent doses and then sees if you're
still going up or still going down and
then since RF - your insulin pump to say
hey have some more or don't don't give
you any more so it essentially creates a
feedback loop where there wasn't a
feedback loop before this sounds pretty
wonderful it is but there's a few
downsides so like I said it really needs
some older pumps the ones that have in
reverse engineered or hacked if you will
since the pumps are usually that old it
means the warranty is worn out so if the
pump breaks you're kind of out of luck
you
you need to get a new pump and then
you're off the system or you have to go
on eBay Craigslist whatever I found some
Facebook groups as well to sell some of
these old pumps and you can buy them
from them but because now these old
pumps which didn't used to be worth much
and how like worth a lot more they're
starting to become more and more
expensive so it's sort of a weird like
retro thing where you know like records
are coming back it's kind of like old
insulin pumps are coming back and newer
pumps aren't compatible med companies
are still like no we're not going to
work with you because you're not FDA
approved in blah blah blah there is an
organization called tide pool and tide
pools train to become the sort of
middleman between the FDA in the tech
companies that are close sourcing me
like we don't want to work with you and
the open source companies that are open
source people that have said we have
good algorithms these are tried these
are true these are tested they work and
so tide pools trying to be that first
middleman corporation to say we want to
work with both of you it also improves
the situation a lot but it's not perfect
a couple days ago I ended up having a
bad typo glycaemia I had ended up
overdosing and the problem is you can't
take your insulin back once it's in you
so you either have to just eat more or
you're bad things happen um so it tried
to rescue me it cut off all my Basil's
and just said like you're not getting
any more insulin and it you know reduced
my curve but it didn't like stop it so
we ended up going hypoglycemic anyway
there's no support from medical
companies I know a lot of doctors are
very much well I've never used the
system I don't know what it is you need
to stick with the newer stuff that you
know companies have made and tested my
doctor was just kind of like she was
doing some blood tests and like your
shirts are really good what are you
doing finally I ended up telling her and
she was like I kind of vaguely heard
about this but if it works for you great
keep doing it because that's what's most
important in the end I mean kinda like
I've said med tech companies they pretty
much hate this thing
partly because they can't control it
make money I think there's probably more
politics in fact they hate it so much
that the same security flaw tends to
keep coming up it's been out for like
eight years or something but they this
is from earlier this year this is a big
oh no bad warning warning cyber hackers
can get into your pump and blah blah
blah which then also then spins off the
FDA it's just like oh my god bad things
are happening you all are gonna die or
something I don't know but it's
basically the same security flaw
constantly and everybody in the you know
type 1 community that's running one of
these insulin pump or artificial
pancreas systems like hey by the way you
know the this is a good security flaw if
there's such a thing yeah so it's kind
of why the downside this is we sort of
have to play this politics game there's
a few different algorithms I'm not going
to dive too much into these but a rough
0 was the original one there's white
papers on it if you're really curious
you can go out and read these things so
basically it just adjusts your basal all
day long so you know if it starts to see
you going high when you shouldn't be it
can bring you back down if you're going
low and you shouldn't be can kind of
bring you back up so it makes really
fine tune adjustments there rf1 is a
newer version of the algorithm where it
adjusts that and then gives you extra
little insulin shots if you will I think
of it like full expresso shots to kind
of like try and bring you back down the
loop was are kind of similar only they
offer extra recommendations if you say I
ate this much it's gonna think like I
think you need to take this much and
then from there you can kind of enact on
it
Android ApS is basically the of0 but
they add some time adjustments to it so
you can kind of adjust how much time it
looks back to make these adjustments
okay so talk for a really long time
who's ready for a live demo
all right um we're going to switch to
mirroring will cook all right tada here
is my body in real-time how exciting is
that okay earlier I was wanted to you so
you can see I'm 103 now so what up just
a tiny little bit um sometimes in
conferences there's a little bit of
signal interferences so my last value up
in the left corner you can possibly see
it said 10 minutes ago so it actually
didn't get one five minutes ago
so hopefully that'll pick back up in a
minute all those points in the middle
the greens and the yellows those are all
the data points over the last you know
few hours and then at the bottom you can
see over a longer period of time
Oh looks like I went low in the middle
of them huh that's weird but yeah this
is over like 36 hours so you can kind of
see like I'm fairly green for most of it
which is pretty good up at the top I
have all this status information so on
the right side under the 103 you can see
the +1 means since the last reading I
went up a value IOB means insulin on
board so right now I have 7.3 units kind
of floating in my body that hasn't been
absorbed yet some of the other things in
the next row are kind of ages of
different things so how old my insulin
is how old the tubing is when the last
time I stuck a since our on different
things like that so I can kind of keep
making sure I don't leave them on too
long and then over on the left oh my
phone's 7% right now that's not good if
I can read all the status information
about my pump too so I have 290 units
stored in it so it's good for a long
time about a reason 1.37 volts so it's
starting to get low but not quite there
different things like that
and then over here there's an open ApS
one so I can hover over that to actually
see how it's calculating the different
things it's too small I can't really
zoom in on it but it shows like all the
different data points it's looking at
and
it's final prediction which at the
moment just says adjust my basil a
little bit the dots in the middle are
all so I took 18 units earlier and then
ate 61 grams of carbs at lunch so those
two are supposed to kind of counteract
each other and then over here on the
left you can kind of see a point two
point two point one point one those are
those micro boluses so that's the
pancreas telling the insulin pump
give me those little tiny things I
thought I was going high so I was trying
to bring me back down and then over the
big blue ranges it might be hard to see
but there's a little dotted line
those are my default values for my
Basil's so the actual blue shaded part
is it's adjustments so there's a couple
parts or it gave me a little bit more
there's a couple parts or it cut me off
different things like that so you can
see those and then finally there's all
those colored dots off to the side some
of those are this is your trend of carbs
which is going to keep going
your trend of insulin and which is going
to go down and then the ones in the
middle are different calculations for
where it thinks it's gonna go so
ultimately it takes an average of all
those to figure out what's going on in
my body so this is me this is live um
I'm gonna stick that over there real
quick and then pull up a terminal I'm
going to plug in my pancreas
because that's what one does right
[Music]
cool um it's name is SAR Borg Sarah
cyborg yeah anyway it's gonna mess up
real quick I don't know why it always
does there we go cool so L is the simple
command that basically prints out the
logs so at the moment you can actually
see literally in real time what is doing
so since you only get a new sugar value
every four minutes it doesn't run
constantly and only runs once every five
minutes to update things so right now
it's been looking for interferences it's
not seeing any of that so it's doing
kind of initial communications between
my pump come on do something fun real
quick running out of time so it also
tracks the time on the pump to make sure
it's within I think 90 seconds just to
make sure it has all the correct doses
whenever I'm manually issuing them it
downloads everything I've done to the
pump so if I gave myself a dose it
downloads that so it can record it into
night Scout um come on do something fun
ok so it's refreshing the pump history
it kind of scroll up a bunch of stuff
here yeah so now it's refreshing my
temporary basil so it's sending a
command that says this is your new basil
rate now and a bunch of numbers are
gonna scroll up there we go and those
are all the kind of statistics it's
doing so it's downloading all those
different values running the analytics
figuring out what's going on and then no
bolus needed so it says you're fine I
think you don't need any extra for all
the food you've eaten so um yeah so
that's basically it just completed that
loop and now it's gonna go to sleep for
a few minutes so kind of nice one of the
things it also does at 4:00 in the
morning every day and I'm gonna run a
version of this locally just cuz it's
faster and this is called auto teen so
it looks at those basal rates that I
programmed into my phone looks at every
hour of the day and sees ok you have
this much insulin you ate this many
carbs what's the difference
and if you're higher than it expects
it's gonna raise your basal rate if it's
lower than it expects it's gonna lower
it but the other thing it can do is
adjust the carburation so that's the
ratio I had programmed in that's the new
one and changes my insulin sensitivity
factor so milligrams per deciliter per
unit so it's adjusting that so we're
pretty on par there's a couple like
hourly ones that are a little bit off
but every night it runs this and kind of
updates me and I can run it locally too
in case I want to change anything so
that's pretty cool right and then
finally I can come in here to reports
and let's say I want to remote run a
report for like last couple weeks or
something I'm just gonna run three days
but it will quickly but there we go do
these reports I could take a look at
data over time see what's changed how
many carbs I had and how much insulin
was given to me I can print this out and
give it to my doctor um I could even
give my doctor access to this website I
can get friends or family access to the
flow update tooth they can kind of keep
track of me so lots of cool things about
the system um instead I'm running out of
time can I go back where I was and for
some reason Linux always puts my slides
on the wrong monitor okay go back
[Music]
because I run Linux on my pancreas why
not run Linux on my desktop they're not
related um I know I'm running low on
time so try and breeze through this real
quickly lots of people to know ask a lot
of the same questions so is it really a
pancreas if it's not inside of you um
I mean no it's not technically a
pancreas it's a open looping hybrid
device it's called the artificial
pancreas just cuz it replicates a lot of
those functions that you sort of do
normally so it's just kind of easier to
say artificial pancreas and they're open
looping hybrid device or something so
wait this is on the internet and it's
giving you medicine can you really trust
it and for the most part I can like I
said there's a lot of research into it
there's white
papers I've looked over these the
algorithms make sense I kind of ran it
through a trial mode where it offered
the suggestions but didn't take action
because you can enter in safety limits
into it and all of the suggestions it
was making if I tried them they worked
and they were working better than my own
suggestions so I'm like I think I can
truly trust this thing if it's online
can't you hack it sure I mean we can
kind of hack anything that's on the
internet because you have to go through
my phone because it's tethered to the
Wi-Fi and then get into the device and
the device is Linux you kind of have to
break into Linux and then you'd have to
like run scripts - I don't know dos me a
bunch of Medicine if you didn't like me
um or possibly break in the night scout
and make adjustments to different things
I don't know I think the level of
complexity to do this is annoying but if
still you wanted to do that the insulin
pump dose is really slowly over time so
I would start to hear it beep because it
beeps every time it starts to make a new
action and if I didn't hear it my phone
would start dinging and be like hey you
know you're going low and you shouldn't
be you need to rescue yourself so
typically I would just just see bad
things are happening and like that's
weird and kind of move on from there
isn't annoying to carry everything
around and it is a little bit so besides
that I have I call the snares diabetic
stuff it's just a whole bag of
everything I have to carry with me and
these are all like the fingerprinting
stuff yeah you got a bag um so I carry
that all around with me I'm waiting for
TSA to stop me at some point like why do
you have a giant bag of needles in your
backpack like yes but I'd like to think
my health is better because of all this
and it's kind of worth a little bit of
annoyance what is the battery dies
because of your course your pancreas can
die I have to charge it but because it
doesn't do that feedback loop I just
kind of go back to manual mode and the
same thing if I lose internet access
because I can't download those values
you can't run the trends I'm sort of the
same thing I just kind of go back to
manual mode so the same thing when I'm
on an airplane I can lose that internet
access
for a bit so I just gonna deal with it
myself why is it not fda-approved it's
kind of complicated there's a lot of
mess behind it essentially this is a
self experiment on yourself it's an
experiment of one so because the FDA
doesn't regulate those you can kind of
do this on your own they don't really
care it's also not a sold device you
can't buy an artificial pancreas so you
buy the parts to build it and then you
build it and then you install it
yourself and you kind of do all the
configuration so they don't regulate
that so why the med tech company's not
done this we kind of talked about the
Medtronic which is gonna everybody I
hear that uses it usually turns off the
looping part just cuz it's not that
great the sensors aren't very good
there's a couple that are still trying
to do it basically it's just expensive
to do all the research into this they
already have pumps that work why do they
need to make a fancier system and then
there's some other politics and won't
get into but basically before I had this
I struggled to keep really good blood
sugars there were high a lot it was very
easy to go over 200 I just sort of
struggled to keep up with this um
afterward you can kind of see after I
turned on the first algorithms I have a
lot of green these values are really
good and you can kind of see at the
bottom all these blues that's justice
for me you can just see in general
there's a lot of activity but once I
turned on the newer algorithm this is
six days of entirely green pretty much
there's a few little tiny red spots six
days worth so much activity going on
here and this is like whether I didn't
eat anything or I just like pinched an
entire pizza kind of stuff like it it
took care of me either way and it's kind
of amazing to have this I also love that
I can go to bed and wake up and I'm
pretty much at like reset every day even
if I took bad care of myself the night
before so kind of zooming in on one of
these this is a literal 24-hour period
where I just had like amazing blood
sugars the whole time in fact at a
previous conference at a type one person
come up and asked a bunch of questions
and
his wife at a party later and she was
like I'm mad at Sara because she has
such good blood sugars and I can't do
that myself
yeah and it's amazing that I don't have
to do anywhere near as much work as I
used to so trying to wrap this up the
code for open abs the instructions are
at read the docs you can go to the
github repo and get open abs on the back
end which is night scout nights night x
trip is the Android app that you can use
to collect the blood sugars if you're
running loop kit which is the iOS only
one the instructions are at github that
I owe you can also download loop kit
Reilly link is that hardware board it's
open-source but unless you have like a
hardware building laboratory in your
basement you're probably going to just
prefer to buy their pre-made ones and
they pretty much do it just you're
paying for the parts they kind of
assembling for free I want to leave you
with kind of how the system can better
people in ways you might not think so
young children that are diagnosed with
this are terrible at managing themselves
their parents usually have to interject
what if they could just run around at
recess and just hold one of these little
devices and it just kind of took care of
things themselves and the nurses can
kind of watch remotely over the internet
to see how the kids are doing they don't
have to come in on a regular basis and
check the kids blood sugar
what if older people that aren't really
good at managing their own medicines and
everything could have a system that did
it form what if those caretakers of the
older people could get those
notifications and know if something is
going wrong what if low-income people
could use some of these older devices
that are cheaper and get better care
from it or those without health
insurance either that can't afford to
buy a brand-new $12,000 insulin pump
they could yeah who's right they're
expensive they're it's ridiculous and
our industry is kind of terrible about
that
um I wanted to give back I've subscribed
to these github repos like I'm gonna
make commits and they're super active
they're constantly being updated I don't
have to do a darn thing
but I realized taking devices flashing
them with operating
systems dealing with Linux get cloning
whatever the heck that means you know
installing bash grips whatever the heck
that these are things that non-technical
people don't know how to do and so this
is a really intimidating system what if
these could be automated what if you
could plug it in it detects the type of
device you have and then you know it
could kind of install itself from there
that's what I've started working on and
unfortunately I doesn't have anything to
show for it finally I want to leave with
you one last point um what if our
software had a greater purpose
what if it wasn't just about delivering
better ads but what if we could solve
problems that even major corporations
didn't want to tackle I just think it's
an amazing thing that we should all kind
of keep in the back of our mind as we
continue to work thank you all for
coming thank you for dealing with this
slightly longer